[Music]
okay
you see who's the hotshot you should
talk about
that's my pick that's the person we're
going to talk about Fabiano's games in
fact okay they love history
I got to know Fabiano and his game back
in 2006 when I played Spain for four in
a very small open tournament well wasn't
that small but okay they were like only
four or five teams a number of items
playing the tournament and he was I
don't know exactly was 13 probably
playing the tournament and already like
2480 almost 2500 within GM norm so close
to a gym level at a time and we played
the game and he he came to the game a
little bit late I think 15-20 minutes
even maybe more I don't know I'm not
sure because she was not staying at this
he was not living the same city was near
Madrid but not exactly the city we were
playing wasn't exactly in Madrid so he
played after the game he he uploading
our top the opening but somehow in time
pressure has swindled him I okay I don't
want to brag about it just I'm telling
this story and then the next I was like
okay this guy is very strong obviously I
mean here two completely outplayed me
out of the opening and at the time I was
close to my pick
I was I was 19 and I was 20 or did gia
for a year had some good results so I
was already impressed very much because
easily out lately and next next day I
started watching his games and ever
since I was I was following his game so
to start with actually I want to go to
this game because this is the very first
game of him not I played against him III
observe I looked at so this is a game
against so far being here is a little
bit over 13 or something 2480
he became a team two months after or
something like in two months it was
already higher than me and
and this game I was following I was very
much impressed because I never played
Sicilian from the white side so the way
he handled it very mature I'm very he
wasn't stuck with the ideas he's been
told he could compose his own idea so
speaking about his estar so generally in
this in this lecture I'm going to talk
about the differences and similarities
between calcium and Caruana
with with with respect to fabulous
talent games we were looking at so here
I'm talking about what parts I believe
he can outperform Caruana
and outperform Carlson which I think one
is that he is more diverse as a player
although it's very hard to say I mean
how think are more diverse I mean
they're very universal players they play
almost everything but still I think he
has a tendency of playing so many things
at this front advisor so this is a game
against an international master and at
the time I used to believe that this
position is playable on the black side
so Castle so usually this nut goes to c6
this Bishop comes to e7 Queen c7 I
actually have to choose a different
color
oops
the special should come here this oh
this row comes to eh Queen c7 right are
you familiar with that game 24 match
Kasparov Karpov 8 1985 that's one game
you should know you should know you
should go and study the game 24 Karpov
is one point behind and Kasparov
plays the system known as polar graphs
key set up and won the game so that's
the usual way to play it for example I
can show you some some line just that
can lead to that the accuracy of the
move order is just it could be in
question I'm just trying to get to the
position so this and after king each one
Queen c7 there are different lines
there's this Bishop f3 line that Rukia
comes and then would be ship to 7
sometimes let's be sure to 7 right away
they used to go this might be 300 is no
exchange to this Knight is a stuck here
and I am planning to play d4 g5 then
there's Bishop drops back Queen goes to
h5 in return blacklist this Meraki 8 so
at some point when you start this attack
the knight goes to d7 and f8 defending
h7 and if f5 the bishops can go can go
to let me do the different color
f8 hello it was supposed to be a
different color I promise oh ah
and then the rook on eh would defend the
pawn on e6 too many arrows again
so that's but again that's that's the
usual way to play it but I believed at
least at the time I thought that okay
this 97 is playable but but it turned
out to be dubious so 97 Castle Knight c5
so I thought okay what already got
something he's forcing f3 and this idea
therefore is never gonna start because
after I play three it which she he has
to play right is there any other move
why why Bishop f3 is not a good move you
think so what's what's our idea one play
45 right eventually yeah
yeah that's that's one thing comes in
mind so we shop here g3 Castle Bishop g2
right and then rook and then Bishop d7
maybe maybe this was also possible but
there's always a c5 line that there's a
c5 that can always be annoying or Bishop
d7 1085 I don't know but this not gonna
see if I at the time I didn't know but I
just not gonna see if I was just
misplaced but again the most important
thing is that the most important thing
here is that black is behind in
development you lost to Tempe with a
knight the night and see if I wasn't
doing much here okay you're attacking
the pawn on e4 but you're under attack I
can go before a for later on you know I
can dismiss the night and keep going
with my attack so losing a lot of Tempe
see how Khurana shows a lot of
creativity in this game
b6 okay now very beautiful move Queen e1
so this is a very famous idea with the
pawn on f4 but nevertheless this is a
playable line because knife Bishop g7 is
not possible there's not c6 right that's
brutal
right and after Bishop e7 I think if you
lady should be servant is here yes we
should be seven Queen g3 now that Bishop
is stuck on f8 okay this is not part of
the my preparation for this lecture but
you can give it a try what's the only
way for black to fight for equality or
or a balanced game
that's the only way actually what
chapter which is this is still it I
think what is better but practically
where the ball is more difficult what
black is he played Queen c7 look t1 and
play it now g6 black has one big problem
which is lack of enough development
right but if I play Bishop g7 or Bishop
e7 then castle then I'm fine and
actually why species are kind of awkward
because he already committed to rook F
to D 1 which is actually very strong
move we'll see later why because you're
going to figure out why and so I cannot
I kind of start any attack on the King
side so if I get my Bishop out of I move
my bishop from f8 and cancel then I stop
b5 d5 you know preparing Luke t8 black
has his usual plan on the Queen side we
got nothing on the King side what should
we do and again some history I was at
the board I I watch the next few Mo's I
couldn't figure out that figure it out
not that not at all but it was like wow
this is interesting because maybe I got
so much used to my old way of thinking
that everything was going through a
specific schema or maybe I wasn't I
didn't have enough creativity so here a
very interesting idea bye-bye white now
I know now it's after years of
experience you figure it that but how
whitey not undermine blacks position
okay I Bishop g7 and then for example I
can drop my knife back to d7
yes that's it a four but why a four a
five what's that
well I grab the pond if you give me
another mumbai castle and i just claim
it up being of a pot
night tp5 you play a four a five to
undermine the night on c5 now this nut
is vulnerable this pawn doesn't have
enough defenders so we go 90 b5 a b5 I
text b5 Queen c6 my text e6 check King
f8 u ships if I take you to check Bishop
e5 excellent now the thing is that if I
go Queen b6 I'm running into a check so
now you can play Knight X piece running
into a pin they can take on b7 and take
on c5 if I go Queen c7 then same thing
Knight takes p7 because now if you take
on g3 I think I'll see if I have it
checked right then take here I will be
up a piece and if I play Queen takes p7
then Queen d6 check this is even more
accurate Bishop c5 Bishop takes d5 is
still it's completely winning of course
but his accuracy is also very no being
it up being a top layer and this layer
it's not all about making good moves you
have to be perfectionist and this is the
strongest move and then Bishop Bishop to
c6 and black has resigned take the rock
take the knight back rank mate and name
how many problems black has 2006
it's the first game so ever since I
started looking at his game one thing
that is common among the elite players
and okay players who are at the world
championship level since there are kids
and this is for this is very important
for kids and coaches I think this is
this point they need to know there they
need to have done their homework and
they need to know their stuff
so next game I'm going to show you he
slept he let the wind step out of his
hand after the game when I discussed the
moves with him he almost had seen
everything all the all the classes all
the things he needed to know about the
position he already knew so I'm going to
show you a position one second so this
is and actually this was very important
for me because okay I should again stop
bragging but but it had had he won this
game he would have won the tournament
solely so he played his line h4 that was
the newest fashion of playing this line
h4 so he was on top of this theory so
then he got this position and c4 very
strong why c4 is a strong wolf I'm good
I'm killing the idea of see c4 for black
these two points are permanent
weaknesses which actually kills this
Bishop and this Bishop like if I were to
offer to offer something to my opponent
I would say I will remove these two C
pawns earring of the pawn on e4 and then
black will have some compensation with
c4 that kills the you know all the
counter play this Knight coming to g6
always has h5 h6 this is really
something really annoying right any
questions about it good
all right all right now g6 King c2 takes
takes rook exchange so what has a
pleasant endgame maybe winning I don't
know probably probably probably winning
switch 595 another excellent White's an
excellent move
one of the ways to win a position is to
know technically what kind of positions
and what pieces you need on board on the
board based on the material so based on
the pawn structure sorry so you know you
know the material you need to win a
certain position here we'll have good
night versus bad bishop the nighttime
big one will become very strong going to
a four that bishop on city is dead if
you want to get it down you have to play
f6e five then that ship on fa will be
dead and see if I was a target why if I
was a target because I can get my knight
on i-4 right this night will eventually
land on i-4 is that right any questions
about that you cannot stop that right
and my bishop will attack this part if
these two knights are out of the are off
the board how can black defend this
policy five a very nice long-term
strategic plan it this is a very typical
you know a grand master level or a bit
higher you know the material you need in
a fixed point structure on the board
that would decide the game for you and
this is not only about [ __ ] a Caruana
but any every every elite player once
they get these things this doesn't get
out of their way okay this game it was
just an exception because it was he was
on his way to become an elite player
rocky one should be seven and this
exchange maybe just simple way with
Knight a four and this would have done
it
I really exactly didn't check but
computer was showing several ways here
but he formed completely winning
position easily ah this actually this f5
gives some active play to black because
he takes but still this take king c1 but
again look at the position what's what's
main advantage pawn structure right
because in fact all these pawns
obviously Okla
actually I have to use a better color
here all eyes with it targets and so
many weakest scores in blacks position
so after
look g6g three rock d6 so now how do
what continue yeah now therefore I take
the rock I'm plucking v6 exactly look
you won and this is game over
well technically I mean if you if you're
gonna run your engine it's just plus one
or something but you gradually grab the
point fluke III you consolidate bring
the knife back and you gradually will go
forward it's not that easy because
Bishop and rook the it's a very nice
combination night and rook is usually
not a very good combination so given
that what should be one of your goals
then that's a really good hint after
taking on c5 Trey looks back to d1
trader looks then winning to pawn up
endgame very important thing also if you
look at the position you see that this
Bishop on a5 is very active but it
doesn't have very reachable goals or
targets these two points are well
protected with the king I see one huh
and I was just black what simply grab
upon them after trading the rooks start
creating a passed pawn the pawns on the
King side are weak and the game will be
over but he here he missed his chance
but this is this is about equal there
was he try for a while he spent a lot of
time and after 93 black choke choke here
and then they agreed on a draw
he played King g3 and they agree on draw
why he didn't try g4 I asked him after
the game and he means they explained
everything for me this is in every
endgame book that's what I meant by know
by every other player from the very
early stage of the of their career as
kids they know the classics they know
their stuff they know what they need to
know in every stage of the game
do not teach openings to kids teach them
chess but he immediately when I asked
him he'll he only knew it's not even
something that he figured out over the
board he already knew that okay so this
is this was my experience I didn't get
to see him anymore
I knew that he's just his rating is just
going up like a rocket reaching the moon
and here's the next time I picked up let
me see which one was these two we looked
at I picked up a number of games showing
his technical ability handling simple
positions and how he hold how he handles
also the very very very complex
positions and positions that neither
side can make so much improvement but
still very sharp let me start with this
game with against Georgia it's not among
the best games of Fabiano but I like the
way he holds the position he manages to
maintain the pressure while not giving
away much advantage and then finally his
opponent cracks down the pressure in
time pressure
let's see three t-64 George Meyer is not
being the best probable player in the
world playing this lying prevention
system with with black we should be
three miss should be seven is on another
line would see five would be six sent
but he I think he played in this game
Bishop d6 we shoved you six Bishop d3
Castle Queen e2 why prepares the long
castle Bishop d7 now pushing the pawns
is not an easy task here I just cannot
stop pushing the pastor's Bishop before
coming guy one of the exchange Queen e75
is coming the center is open you cannot
just start pushing the pawns why you
cannot again the center is open what it
has to do with pushing deposit on the
side yes why I say you cannot just start
pushing the pawns on the side because
the center is open yes and once there is
a conflict in the center it's mainly to
a lot of exchanges a lot of exchanges
that means you could I tackle fizzle out
and the pawns have been posted it could
never go back and then they can become
beacons instead of ways to have
advantage instant means to advantage the
ship g5h six mission which 4x4 was
another possibility obviously taking and
this is not possible of course if this
night most and there's fresh herbage 7
check and then mate will follow after
night moves and then Queen goes here
that's too much
well of course seat XD 494 we should be
7 takes takes and the 936 okay that's
that's a lot of that's a lot of moves
and then
isn't this winning yeah this is winning
that's about okay I don't I didn't want
to talk about this time but as for was
probably a better choice that's what I
meant just maintain the pressure and
creating a chance of having this up
having the hook moving forward so much
image for this one is a bit dubious rook
c8 c3 Bishop e7 now black has put
everything together everything is
well-protected
the idea with g4 is not going to work
because I just can't take win takes if I
really cannot make use of that hook and
on the other hand on this side black can
start doing things so 6496 t4 rook c5
very strong off this is a very strong
move you're ready to always counter
anything it on the default with the rook
and now I can I have this idea and see
this call is a very good score for the
Queen in this position it is operating
along this file so it's out of the
dangerous D file and it very well
protects the pawn on e6 there Queen c8
another fine move it should be 597 so a
bit of repetition if v is not a move
here because we just go Knight f5 attack
initial counter-attack and we have this
nice square now white might get a
winning attack all right away so if you
play Rubinstein prevention and French
defense you don't want to touch this
pawn less you're sure you get something
really really big just don't touch this
nine pack T of 6h for going after thee
Rock t 8 well G for doesn't work here
unfortunately why there's a tactical
reason no no I G for Black has something
here
why G for doesn't work because now it
seems very clear g5 is coming and then
it's devastating right okay 95 if I go
back here look see three exactly if I go
back here know what yeah I think that's
the move actually just take on h4 if
something is rolling your way either
capture it or just block it better to
capture it if you can
so I think this is not this is not so
nice so I'm sure you calculate through
this and then decided to go Bishop e5 h
very very strong move now if not another
advantage of this rook on c5 I cannot
take here because this richtofen's this
pawn is five this kills the hook now g4
so f3 he was preparing the move to there
and then black makes a mistake here he
black could play 97 probably then after
that would be a repetition I discern
Bishop back Knight back to f6 and what
can I make so much progress so here he
played Bishop d6 and once he got his as
you can see so Bishop h4 wasn't a good
move
after that white maintains the pressure
color wanna handle the pressure very
well kept kept the momentum going on
well I was a momentum he he maintained
the pressure the game was going very
very sharp well no but not nothing was
happening so he was more of maneuvering
but back and forth a little bit of
improvement here and there and here
black tried to solve the problem became
impatient and then here comes the chance
for 4
for white well these six or f6 you want
to pop the king right Bishop f6 nah
G for interesting if i working at shades
right actually G for
what if I take on g4 actually okay that
that falls okay close for now I play
Bishop e5 right if you played let me
make the most here he quiz read what he
played actually but I didn't mean that
it's the only way to play it
but g4 is definitely a possible move
here here is what I missed
here there's rookie five now we know
what was happening
Bishop before yeah I can't take it so
okay now we have the answer
good so so queenie still actually have
to give it a very a lot of credit
because now f4 the idea is that i do not
exchange pieces so doc g8 and then
Bishop c2 I really like and also Bishop
City another advantage of Bishop c2 is
that opens this the file for the stroke
so I win a very valuable tempo because
now this 96 or 95 that both threats so I
have to lose a tempo with my bishop the
mission goes to b3 not a king e6 and
after a 596 I am not sure if this line
is entirely correct like it's going to
relate to a demolishing attack but I
like the way he handles it this is
winning this position I'm for sure is
winning and verse it's very simple black
has two nice bishops and what are they
doing they're looking here
but her Majesty I mean not your majesty
the king is his Highness is here they're
not doing anything so and also this this
one doesn't do anything so basically
after Rocky's six I have one two three
four pieces attacking and there are two
two defenders so it's a it's a simple
math of you know you have more attackers
push it before King gave one okay why
just black is trying Queen f6 now this
this check on the cheeks is killing it
and then after a few moves also this was
a possibility okay chase
very elegant idea
nice mate that's a nice one
but okay this is good enough
yet their work is different okay next
one I am not sure if I will have time to
cover everything so I'll show one recent
game of Fabiano against Hikaru Nakamura
that is a very complex game I really
you'll enjoy it and then I'll talk about
the differences and similarities between
Carwin and Coulson
so here is one of the things that I want
to talk about about Caruana
maybe it could be better than Carlson is
that his willingness to play unbalanced
position with unbalanced material I
think he shows more bidding us to play
this risky becomea physicians and rely
on his creativity more than Carson's
intuition I find Carl sent Caruana to be
more calculation based I seem to be very
similar to Kasparov a dynamic player of
course with a very high depth of
understanding of a strategy play and
position but is his more he's better at
calculation and filling for the active
positions than being intuitive and not
that constant cannot handle this kind of
positions I'm going to show you in this
game but I find the Caruana being more
building more interested in this kind of
positions of course the question is
whether Carlson would let him to get
such such kind of positions to play
that's another that's another story but
let's look at this game so Sicilian yes
neither of what a nice way to wrap up a
lecture right in Nice rough huh
and Bishop g5 this one is put probably
just for this Bishop g5 we can write a
600-page long encircle encyclopedia only
for this Bishop g5 being the it's been
highly deeply investigated and still
there are positions that there are
working on it and they're not no answer
for them or they may we have to look at
the correspondent games nowadays because
it's all game between two
supercomputer so so it's six bishop
which four and a pair and funny thing is
that this game okay one one famous thing
you know you cannot take here of course
the queen is trap so that's that's the
key with this a three move you should
have to and again when the resolves this
x-ray here there's always this Knight
takes e4 Knight takes e4 Knight takes c3
trick so this Bishop of two earns a very
nice temper for you Queen f3 and
obviously once the Queen has already
settled on c7 Queen of three is a good
move and now what has white gained wide
last number of cup of Tempe right but
what white gain is that he is going to
plays usual plan this time there's no
Bishop on Jeeva on the way that's very
and we already have a hook on gh6
it's 97 long castle p5e 5 runs into
Bishop e7 obviously g4 and g5 typical
idea now if I take on g5 that's a
horrible move black will have this juicy
school on a 5 and then we have no
attacked running so I have to go out in
opening up the game H for now XG 5 is a
threat I have to take on a 4 to 3 this
is square for my knight Bishop e2 and I
cannot really comment on this but there
were three corresponding game which
actually from 2014 so it very fresh
among 2400 players so you can't believe
that this was well investigated deeply
analyze position and there was one way
for white and there was a 3-2 draws and
if there were one win that means that
this is this line is over this is not
good for black so I played before this
has also been played it takes before so
the point is that I I can go with this
rook g8 or row p8 but my plan is not g5
so let's see what what it says about g8
actually Wow I thought chief I was the
main line I remember exactly in the 96
oops
now I can't tell me what happens if I
take here
nice now you're really losing your queen
yes Bishop is five check you pin me I
pin you so this and then I have eight
mischievous 556 I think it's one of
those Correspondence games actually so
after Luke takes now you want to win the
piece taking on g6 Bishop back to see it
and then oops what did that come from
because Bishop g6 we take take and Queen
f7 with two bishops only one pound
probably black and hold but this is this
is a killer probably and why he doesn't
take probably I can play a rook F one
maybe the bishop then there's we should
be seven well that's this is beyond me
maybe I can win the pawn maybe listen
let's ask our friend starfish it's a
killer
so if takes takes takes takes King d8
King up simply this huh now simple as
that and the point is I think we have
this queen of seven so the distraction
is that I play we should be sick so I
want the couny f7 later so and the Queen
cannot move anywhere else because of
course this loses to this is checkmate
and if going here is just as bad I think
you just I take here
huh Wow
the difference is that there's this root
if one now I still cannot touch the
Queen go into g7 that's fantastic but
anyways yeah this is this looks very
dubious this this looks very suspicious
to say the least so so be for a be 495
this is another corresponding game that
I was looking at night 64 here too is
strong okay
black was high rated player white was
low rated corresponds player like 1800
and they agreed on draw in this position
there okay yeah that's that's funny
what about after e5 then I'm taking on
g4 it's just crazy right everything's
all over the place Queen takes f6
I have five and I have two pieces and
they upon know I have two pieces but
look look at this
no knight c6 doesn't get anywhere I have
at least a kanji for and they take back
on d8 that's it but that's the least I
have yes that is coming so repeat has
been played Bishop a5 just I simply take
take and I start just to dominate that's
another correspondents game that's the
one probably Nakamura missed and black
just dominates I'm sorry what wait just
a minute
okie seven can be won and then actually
the funny thing is that black here
resigned in the corresponding scape and
if you and if you run the engine it
shows plus something and then it grows
on that 3035 so I just didn't bother
that suggested and it's on my laptop I'm
talking about not a super computer or
something so narrow p8 and I have six
and then he just played it very he
handled it very well for one of this he
found this poem of course technology for
his not possible not x86 Queen drops
back check their fishery five black is
out completely out of love nothing to do
and ok the simple way he played b5 first
and then took what 9f seven is just
winning
in the game played b5 Queenie ed takes
takes rook takes Queen takes check and
they resign obviously the final phase is
that I mean I have this check probably
right and I have this check I have this
check right or I just let it go let's
just see I think this makes sense right
okay check here
now check right and another check
another check
do you let it go
ah I think I have this chick right and
this makes more sense
at least half bishops if I've checked
and taken take take the rock there
no no that's why this should work
what are we missing no this which we
check should be over this fun why what
am I missing here well I go back on that
shade that's no well the pond on between
under attack I think some the chicks
should decide this game ah my bad after
take I keep forgetting about this chick
okay there we are
yeah and I looked check and then you
grab the Queen that's it I couldn't see
the rookin be it basically yeah that's
checkmate
so that was done with my points
I was literally so tired that I - I
wrote my notes that's what I wanted to
say about the difference it says and
similarities so the strengths that I
consider chaotix risk and is more
diverse than Magnus I mean it's quite a
statement right speaking about Magnus
not being as diverse as car one but I
think the point I want to make is that
he lives car one likes the unbalanced
position in terms of material like if
you have rock embassy versus rook and
Bishop I probably believe that cousin
can handle that better but if the
material comes have an unbalanced like
rougane to power for two pieces or I
think Caruana
has equal chances there or sometimes
maybe even better
I'm not necessarily just with sacrifices
just if the material is not balanced
night versus bishop well again we're
talking about just that godly techniques
comparison so it's just not was a very
observation I looked at the games he won
against Carlsen I think that whenever
such complications come up even if it's
in favor of Carlsen sometimes he managed
to trick him and get get good results so
they're both very technically savvy but
obviously we all know that probably
causes the best technical player ever in
the history of the game so that's
something they're both very good at
technical chess but Lucy Kelson is the
best and they're both way original
players they have a lot of knowledge of
classics and that they play with
original chess when it comes when it
matters so we'll see what that for so
it's going to be a lot of fun watching
the match in London in November thank
you
[Music]